what's with the jeans hey I don't know
where you're going next but do you want
to play the thing that I brought in yeah
what's okay so do you want to set this
up because I don't really know like tell
them okay what you did well so on that
deep bro I had a licensed
psychotherapist on mark mark Barone was
on and he's from Seattle and we talked
about Carl Jung and synchronicity and I
thought since I have a therapist online
why not have him assess your artwork and
give an analysis on what he thinks is
going on there
this I legitimately I had never heard
you just said play this I said what am i
playing go oh just just play it this
planet so you had him look at it so this
is a Skype session with a
psychotherapist and we finished that too
deep bro and I go hey one more thing can
you look at my husband's artwork and
just tell me what you see in the art if
it's normal and my Instagram I emailed
him a screen grab of of the painting
that you did home at last home at last
so when you say the painting I have to
figure out which one okay so this is
what you did in Denver okay this is fun
Instagram so the listeners can go to
your Instagram cigarette Tom and look at
this quote painting or at work and let's
just see what a licensed psychotherapist
says about okay what what is it so with
me is Mark Peron he is a licensed
psychotherapist hi mark
thank you for joining me I really
appreciate this yeah so um I I just
emailed you my husband's artwork that he
did he stayed in a condo in Denver and
like all the comedians leave behind a
piece of art for the home the house that
they stay in and first of all what are
your credentials um in the psychotherapy
we could just let us know your
background which means I have the master
master of arts in psycho so but
basically you are a you're a
professional mental health person yes
for a while okay so I've sent you the
artwork but we've been discussing if you
could take a look at it and just tell me
what do you see here what what would the
mental health of a person making this
type of artwork what what does it look
like and please be honest well there's
there's a lot what I've never seen right
away is there's a lot of phallic energy
here interesting there's a first of all
there's this gun that's pointed and I
don't know if this is a self-portrait or
not I think you might be yeah so there's
this gun with it with a with a in its
purple a purple gun with a red kind of
some fire kind of shooting out of the
front of it huh
and then it's got this it looks like a
male figure space so the gun is pointed
towards his face and the other phallic
element is that he's got a really long
tongue that's hanging out huh
that's now so it indicates that there's
some you know maybe a fear of this of
this entered maybe this nurse there's
this sorry I think there's the way that
he's looking at it that is his eyes are
really like bulging out so it's like
there's this like you know a fear or
like obsession you know dick obsession
yeah
this energy sounds about right what's
interesting is that above his head and
above the gun there's this there's this
kind of half half circle above him which
which which looks feminine I would say
it's a dark Sun I told him but just
listen and it's in it's black it's it's
pitch black
oh yeah and so that's kind of like
hovering above him so there's like this
this female energy which is like you
know dark and mysterious and powerful is
above is above him and then and then
he's uh he's kind of you know like bound
by this you know this this his own
energy you know and then there are these
these little figures down at the bottom
this they kind of look like like flames
as well
they're bushes they're bushes I just you
know the I'm sorry was your husband's
birthday April 16th four days from the
fears sceneries yes uh yes so fire he's
a fiery guy very so actually that but I
tell you that what I actually painted
was my second option oh really what was
the first well first of all should tell
you this the way that I drew that
painting it's the way that I draw you
too with the bulging eyes and the nose
it's my go to profile yeah I know the
the first option that I was gonna do it
I only had second thoughts I was like ah
I don't know if they'll hang it up here
I was just gonna draw a big cock with
balls and have it just shooting jizz out
onto the you know and isn't that
interesting that marks assessment is
really because the tongue is kind of a
cock kind of sort of how I would have
drawn it there's yeah yeah there's a
dick shooting its load at you're in your
mouth yeah is it a self-portrait no
continue any part is this on the ominous
yeah I don't by the way I don't hear
mental illness like you like to bring up
black that black thing he said is
supposed to represent this it's the Sun
yeah I got that to you but it looks it's
a black sign and it's in its shape like
it's kind of shaped like a breast
right an oppressive female breast energy
energy kind of like dampen his fire I
wonder who that fiery science and not
surprised I'm really not surprised that
that there's this fiery fiery energy
there I'm sorry so that's what you see
in those those bushels those things are
fire yeah sexual energy would you say
sexual or creative energy you know it
can be they can be kind of one in the
same so you're dampening my creatives
yes I'm breaking your spirit essentially
like you have all this phallic energy oh
nice here's somebody else I mean that's
what I've been trying to get out with
Merritt work well it's actually a little
more than that if you want to keep the
energy I would say is usually identified
as sexual in our culture you know
there's this focus on you know male
energy and you know everybody right
everything you know the Freudian I think
libidinal energy you're redirecting it
you're creative and I'm I'm obviously
squashing your the dark cloud amazes
uh-huh sex right so that's the narrative
I'm not saying that that's true but
still what he's really looking at is the
gun which really I think overtly
represents sexuality and then the little
bunches of flames underneath it or maybe
more just the creative energy that is
coursing through his veins all the time
hmm interesting and then the impressive
sorry isn't here this makes sense no I
love it and then the oppressive female
figure that's dampening his sexual
energy is that what you're saying
I love have always been scared of you I
know that's why I love it that someone
else sees it yeah I love it I love it
love having an expert isn't it great you
should have Marc do more of your artwork
yeah and also I'd like to have a gallery
person assess it as for value C and I
wanted to get a real artist to critique
it and actually I I tried and I saw it
in time by the way that Shauna
recognized like real recognize real art
talent yeah and then another artist used
my piece for inspiration all right that
was great yeah yeah Wow okay so he did
really did you see what he did I did it
was really so it's I re posted it on my
Instagram it is not so much better it's
like a real artist in it you know love
it difficult because the drawing is
fraught with horrible things terrifying
things do you I think it's I think it's
I think it's great I think he has a
healthy potentially healthy a youthful
energy about him that's interesting
because he is 57 years old yeah
sometimes incorrectly you know yeah the
old man he's very spry yeah he's very
very kind of breast of of could be oh
you let him continue thing I'm 57 yeah
you're horrible person so that's good
fun it also just be you know that having
to be having to be this this adult you
know interesting yeah that made the the
the power that tells him no to his
penile desires no you know to this to
this idea you know what an adult male
was supposed to be interesting so yeah
that would make sense he just this is my
husband
our work and he just had a child with me
and yeah that makes a lot of sense so
there you know he's yeah you know what's
hilarious the tongue at the time the
same thing out you know it's just so
whimsical you know it's just kind of
whimsical and code for somebody it's
like yeah there's this obvious like have
to be a parent but also you know being a
youthful kind of play this guy reminds
me of my cousin bribry yeah wait he
sounds he's sweet he's very sensitive I
keep going there's no I mean that's the
assessment of your artwork i there's
there's more detailed if you want to
listen to it later I also asked him if
you were normal because you watched so
much murder all the murder shows yeah do
you want to know the answer sure he said
that actually yes because you're in
touch with your dark side and that it's
it's really a healthy expression of
being in touch with one's dark side so
there you go you're I asked him to rate
you on a scale of one to ten your mental
health and he said I you know in all
fairness is like I can't really do that
because I kind of familiar with both of
you from the show the podcast and I
can't do that but I'd give him like an
eight eight meaning I'm a scale of 1 to
10 your mental health
oh he listens to this show yes oh and
he's familiar you know it's kind of
biased
sounds like he's a really cool guy he's
sweet yeah you told him 57 I did yeah
well I was i I thought he asked me how
well does he look I've been all fairness
I forgot okay so just so he knows now
solutions to this show I am 36